welcome to this meeting of baber
District Council cabinet I'm councilor
John Ward deputy and acting leader of
beaver District Council and we're
chairing this meeting
may I remind you of some domestic
Arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending a meeting to speak
persistently interrupt the meeting you
may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or Switched Off
and finally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern.gov app
so please can members make sure they are
logged in and ready to use the app
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeating dealing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed by
entering this meeting as a speaker you
are also consenting to being recorded by
the castle and to the possible possible
use of those images and sound recordings
for webcasting and all training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting from the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
luck now to move to the agenda item one
apologies for absence
thank you chair I have received
apologies from um councilor Sally Davis
and the council Potter thank you item
two to receive Declarations of pecunery
or other registerable or
non-registerable interests by members
any other energy to declare members of
the cabinet
nope
item three paper BCA 2315 to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the 5th
of September 2023 are there any points
regarding the accuracy of these minutes
in which case may I have a proposal
please
councilor Davis counselor Derek Davis
and mayor have a second day
Council Carter
so Governor's officer will now conduct
the vote
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
councilor Derek Davis uh
uh may I have your vote please
it's not come through I'm afraid
thank you chair that is the four votes
for and two abstentions so that's
carried thank you
I do five questions by counselors
item four sorry I skipped that one
didn't I to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
Castle's petition scheme
non-received chair and item six math is
referred by the overview scrutiny or
joint audit and standards committees
there are no matters referred chair
and item seven the forthcoming decisions
list members of the cabinet uh do you
any of you have any comments on the
decisions list
okay thank you
item eight paper BCA 2316 the variation
of the agreement of the shared Revenue
partnership
and I'll now introduce the support as
the cabinet member for finance assets
and Investments
so I'm pleased to introduce paper BCA
2316 the variation of agreement of the
shared Revenue partnership
the SRP is a joint committee of baber
the mid-suffolk district councils and
Ipswich Borough Council hosted by
Ipswich Borough Council which was formed
in 2011 to discharge the functions of
the shared revenue and Benefit Service
for the three councils anyone can attend
its meetings and view agendas and
minutes on the Ipswich Borough Council
website
a review of The partnership agreement
has been carried out and at its meeting
on 6th of September the committee
proposed the deed of variation to the
partnership agreement
this has now been recommended for
approval by the executive and cabinet
Committees of the department councils
there was an early Adida variation in
2015 which is summarized in section 5.3
this new data variations provided in
appendix a and some and also summarized
in section 5.4
the proposed amendments to the agreement
are firstly General housekeeping and
update updating of the agreement to
reflect the changes that have taken
place following the 2015 data variation
the inclusion of calling procedures
previously there was known mechanism for
counselors to question decisions
short calling five days in total is is
provided for because decisions may need
to be be enacted quickly
and finally inclusion of the scheme of
delegations
appendix B contains the Full partnership
agreement showing those amendments and
appendix C lists the functions delegated
to officers by the shared Revenue
partnership
I'd like to give my thanks to Shirley
jarlet the assistant director for
governance and monitoring officer at
itchy Spirit Council who is here today
along with Bob Palmer
who both are here to answer any
questions
so I would now like to propose the
recommendations in in the paper and ask
for a second but please
Council saw
members of the cabinet do you have any
questions
no questions
okay I'll ask any other counselors
present um Council McLaren do you have
any questions yep
obviously the addition to this is the
calling procedure which we
've not um
will that be the process be any
different to what we have normally
the routine crime procedure to other
viewers scrutiny I don't think it will
obviously there's the five-day limit but
I think in terms of anything else the
calling procedure will be pretty much
the same as it currently is
and I just asked another sort of side
question
um I was surprised actually that um that
was there because there's many
counselors
are not aware of the work of the shared
record I mean I found it very
interesting committee
um
I was wondering how counselors would get
to know the information to
make the calling in terms of publicizing
the uh the minutes of meetings that's
surely is are you able to provide any
further information on the calling
process and and more particularly
ensuring that members of the three
councils are aware of the committee's
deliberations
has been added because I feel it was an
Omission in the first place because of
course the Joint Committee has delegated
authority from the executives or
cabinets of the three councils so call
in should apply it is the normal
procedure so your procedure at Babel
would apply and it would go to overview
and scrutiny committee and the
monitoring officer would make those
arrangements
um so far as knowing about the decisions
it's a public meeting so in the same way
you would get to know about the cabinet
meeting decisions today it would be
exactly the same it's a public meeting
and the minutes are published
very welcome to attend any of the
meetings and I know the committee has
has previously sought to to publicize
the work of of the partnership
thank you
chair oh councilman crawl
yeah the mid-suffolk representatives
have already said they'd be quite happy
to provide a short report after each of
the srps
meetings as the baber one of the baber
representatives on the ACT on the
current chair of the committee I'm more
than happy to provide that I don't
anticipate it being longer than a single
page of A4 as a as a brief summary just
to make people aware of what the SRP has
done without meeting
be okay
thank you councilor
if there are no further questions we'll
move into debate does anyone from the
cabinet wish to
make any comment
so can I conclude that we're all happy
with the deed of variation
excellent well we'll move to the boat
then
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
thank you members that is uh six books
for that's carrot
okay you know moving on to the next item
it's item nine paper BCA 2317 the cost
of living a review of the six month plan
and
oh yes sorry yes I've just been reminded
we are moving items 9 and 1910 around
um to um because to allow Shaheem Warren
to um uh take part
earlier rather than later so item 10
paper BCA 2318 the corporate plan
refresh
so I'll now introduce a report as acting
leader of the council
I'm pleased to introduce paper BCA 2318
the corporate plan refresh the current
corporate plan was drawn up by the baber
and mid-suffolk administrations after
the late 2019 elections and now
following the elections this year it is
right that the new administration's
update this in line with their new
priorities
furthermore since 2019 the districts now
have new challenges and opportunities to
focus on
it will always be the council's role to
provide high quality services but we are
ambitious and want to see our towns and
communities really thrive
since the May elections our new
Administration has been delivering an
initial action plan which includes a
relaunch and neighborhood plans a pride
in your place program
and to be able to enable owners of
listed buildings to benefit from
advances in more energy efficient and
zero carbon Technologies to implement a
consider contractor scheme and finally
to promote community Transport
but we've also been working on a
long-term vision and our strategic
priorities together with that to make
Bieber even better
and I would like to remind everyone we
are already one of the best places to
live in the UK
the vision and strategic priorities that
will underpin the refreshed corporate
plan can be found in appendix a and now
the result of workshops and other
meetings that we've had since May
our vision is built on three themes
firstly we'll take the lead and respond
to the challenges of climate change and
protecting and enhancing our natural and
historic environments
secondly we're ambitious for our
communities economy and young people
thirdly strong communities will be built
on good housing well-being and pride in
the place we live
as part of the refresh process we have
agreed that we will engage with our
communities businesses partners and
other stakeholders on the vision and
priorities for the next few weeks
we will be making a particular effort to
engage with groups that represent seldom
heard voices in our communities to
ensure we hear from everyone
our message to the public is this is
what we think what do you think
we want people to tell us what they like
what they don't like what they think
we've missed and what matters most to
their community
we want to capture wide range of views
from a diverse group of people
sure we want everyone to help shape the
future of their own communities
why is it so important to get over this
right
well we need to put ourselves firstly
obviously in the shoes of today's
teenagers
where they'll be in another 20 years and
think about what Legacy we have left for
them
when they look back what are they going
to say we should have done more of what
are they going to be angry with us about
serious long-term change takes time
discussion and thought it also requires
us to listen to and work with our
communities
I would like now to introduce Shaheen
Warren principal practice lead from you
local one of our partners who will be
delivering the community engagement
and she also has a short presentation on
the engagement we're intending to
undertake
first I'd like to propose the
recommendation in section three of the
report that we should endorse closed
engagement and ask for a secondary
councilor saw thank you
so Shaheen over to you for the
presentation thank you
hey frenzy train schedule to move things
around and so my name is Shaheen Warren
I am the principal practice lead and
organization called new local and we
have been partnered with baber and
mid-suffolk District Council and teams
to help with and advise on the corporate
plan refresh specifically looking at how
do we incorporate an engagement plan
with communities residents staff and
other partners and to be able to inform
and enrichen that kind of future road
map and action plan and I have a very
small connection to this part of the
world in that my in-laws live in Long
Melford and so I'm familiar with the
patch a little bit I'm looking for
forward to digging in even deeper and
kind of exploring lots of other
wonderful things that this region has to
offer and I'm going to take you through
a sort of overview of the engagement
strategy and some of the design
considerations that we've been working
through and then cover what does that
mean for the activities that we'll
deliver over the next few weeks and then
we'll take some time at the end for any
questions that you might have
just to kick us off
um a little bit about new local for
those of you who are unfamiliar with us
so we are an independent not-for-profit
Think Tank and we have three kind of
core service offerings and we are home
to and maintain a network of 70 plus
councils up and down the country of
which baber mid-suffolk is part of that
Network and that network is United and
behind the idea of community power and
it's in its simplest form it's the
belief that communities voice has a
vital role to play in the delivery and
sustainability of community-led Public
Services we then have a small But Mighty
research and policy team that explores a
number of different issues that are
relevant to local government today from
climate change to social care to
building economic resilience and how we
might apply and address those changes
through a community-powered approach and
then very finally and I belong to the
practice team which is all about taking
those wonderful ideas and implementing
them into action so working alongside
councils and local authorities and to
collaborate with people and their
communities and their Partners to really
deliver that long-standing and
transformative change
this is just a map of the councils that
are part of our Network are spread
across geography but also we work with
all different political stripes and on
the right hand side is a list of our
corporate Partners who are also
interested in partnering with the public
sector and driving Community powered
change within their own organizations
and in partnership with councils
so then to move us on to our project and
just to say that we have been working
very closely shoulder to shoulder and
hand in hand with the paper mid-suffic
District Council project team so I'm
representing the work of many many
people across the council here and
indeed a new local
um as well and we have spent around the
last kind of six weeks or so
um thinking about what is the engagement
process that really responds to and will
generate the insights that are going to
enrich in the future corporate plan for
the district council and the engagement
plan is specifically targeted at
communities and residents primarily
partners and so business Community towns
and Parish councils and others and some
internal staff engagement to think about
the implications of that plan and the
insights for future road maps so broadly
you can kind of fold the engagement into
two categories there's some internal
facing engagement that we'll do with
officers and staff and then some
external facing engagement which is
really bulk of our work here to drive
those insights from communities and
residents around the emerging priorities
and just to give you a rough sense of
timelines and we hope to launch the
engagement this week and we will then
continue to engage with communities
residents and others until the 15th of
November and the plan is to be able to
feedback those insights to inform the
future council plan
um pre-Christmas
uh so you have a very ambitious agenda
um covering lots of different ground
um and this is a note to say that
whilst we will maintain the sort of core
purpose and Essence across all of the
priorities you might notice that we use
different languages for the different
audiences that we go
um out to and that is really to do two
things one is to make the language
accessible and understandable by a wide
range of people and communities and then
secondly to make them meet the
engagement that we do around the
priorities really meaningful and so
people should be able to relate each of
the priority areas to their everyday
lives be able to see the impact
um in the things that they do and in
their realities and be able to give a
response that is
um both kind of impactful and meaningful
in the context of where they're engaging
which I'll get on to in a second
so the means that we will do that
um are um and kind of what we want to
learn and how we want to learn it
um are represented on this slide
um so if you look at the right hand side
you'll see that we have a very broad
kind of content framework
um for the topics that we're going to be
Consulting on
um and so very broadly that splits out
into four different categories uh one is
to go in and ask people what their
perspectives are on thriving communities
which is a big ambition within your
draft priorities and with within the
draft plan at the moment and there's a
sentiment that we want to maintain but
we also think it's really interesting to
see what that means today and how that
is lived within the communities of baber
and we'll then move on to asking people
what their perspectives and feelings are
about the draft priorities and we also
want to understand how people feel about
the existing spending profile what they
might change about that in the future
and then very finally and really
important to new local as an
organization we want to be able to tell
you what are the existing strengths in
all the communities what are the assets
what are the initiatives that are
already happening and what might drive
that really purposeful collaboration
with your communities and partners in
the future the way that we will do that
is also twofold and so we will have an
online survey hosted on citizen lab one
that is tailored specifically for the
majority of voices so residents and
communities who are digitally connected
you can easily engage in an online
survey and then also a tailored survey
for the business community that asks
them very specific questions related to
them and their needs and then secondly
um we will have some more facilitated
sessions for perhaps those communities
who are not digitally connected or don't
find it easy to connect online but also
typically those seldom heard voices that
are neglected from conversations like
this and one of the big focuses of this
engagement is to be as inclusive as
possible so we've done a lot of work
with the project team here to really
understand who are those communities
where do they exist and how best to
reach them and involve them in this
exercise
um so this just gives you um a highlight
of
um who um like what are the groups that
we'll be engaging with so again we've
worked with
um internal staff here at the district
council to identify which are the groups
that are going to be able to be involved
in the engagement process and inform the
future corporate plan so moving from the
right box
um across to the left uh we'll be
engaging with a number of different
partners and through this work mainly
towns and Parish councils the business
community and the vcsf community will
have some engagement for staff
internally but really that is to
understand what are the future
implications of the insights that are
emerging from Community engagement and
like I said we'll be engaging with
residents and communities in lots of
different ways in order to obtain their
perspectives on the draft priorities
I want to talk a little bit in detail
about what we are going to do for those
seldom heard communities and this table
shows the different groups that are
prioritized for this piece of Engagement
and of course this is kind of a
non-exhaustive list like this could be
expanded a lot more than it is right now
but we went through a process with
corporate managers here to really
understand what information do we
already have about some of the seldom
heard groups that we've identified and
that was to understand if any of that
data can be used in informing the
priorities and the future corporate plan
but also to kind of limit consultation
fatigue in the community so not going
back to the same communities and asking
the same questions but thinking about
the resources that we already have to
inform
um so on that basis we added in
communities and we've also discounted
some and then we've also thought about
where are the gaps in our knowledge what
are the communities that we don't hear
from enough where we don't have enough
connection and how might we reach out
into those communities so then on the
right hand side of the table you'll see
some of the anchor organizations that
are really helping us to access those
group groups and create those
connections
um and it's been actually overwhelmingly
positive response from your vcsf
community and I want to say that because
that's not true with the many partners
that we work in up and down the country
we don't always get such an enthusiastic
response and they have been incredibly
helpful in helping build the inroads
make the connections and helping us to
set up for what I think will be a really
successful engagement process moving
forward and to say one more thing about
our approach here is that we will tailor
to the different groups and it's about
meeting people and convening people in
the spaces where they already feel
comfortable and safe meeting them where
they are and then tailoring some of that
earlier content framework that you saw
so that people can really have
meaningful engage with the key questions
that we're trying to ask them
um a note on the partner engagement so
as you'll see here and we think it's
really important to involve um a number
of different partners but we understand
that that sometimes that's not always
possible
um and so we don't underestimate the
power of informing others to keep them
in the loop about how the corporate plan
refresh is evolving and what we're
learning from communities
um as the engagement process progresses
and so what that means is that
neighboring councils in public sector
institutions will get regular updates
from us and where we find opportunities
for collaboration and learning we will
highlight those to the relevant
organizations for the vcsf community
we're doing a sort of two-fold
Engagement with them one is to connect
with them to help facilitate those
conversations with seldom heard
communities the other is to actually
engage those organizations on the draft
priorities and really engage both the
big anchor organizations and the smaller
ones on
um the priorities and kind of understand
from the people who serve those kind of
diverse communities and what they need
to see in the in the kind of future
corporate plan and and how they feel
about the priorities and then very
finally there'll be opportunities in
both the business community and the vcsf
engagement for councilors to join and we
will very soon be sharing details of how
to do that
um so then very finely
um before I take questions uh what will
happen next
um so fingers crossed we will go live
very soon with both the online survey
and the engagement activities and we'll
be sharing invites to some of the
sessions that we've included including
specific lunches and events that you're
able to attend
um our asks um from you are we would
love for you all to be able to spread
the word so we're going to be equipping
you with posters and postcards and links
to surveys and so that you were able to
share them widely in your networks
um you are the community facing
um kind of assets that we have here in
the council so we hope that you will be
able to do that and we also want to host
sessions to help you do that confidently
um so we will be offering
um kind of training sessions
facilitation sessions so that if you
want to come along to any of them you
feel equipped to do so
um and also you know if you want to have
individual conversations with your
communities
um you are you feel confident going into
those and eliciting those different
perspectives there if you have
recommendations about where else we
should be going we would love to hear
from you and so please do come and talk
to us um and and maybe we can talk a
little bit about that in the Q a
um and then just where we are on
progress we we've got about 24 events um
planned and upcoming with equal split
over both baber and mid-suffolk patches
and with a good spread across all of
those seldom heard voices and
communities that we mentioned earlier
I'll pause there and happy to take any
questions thank you
thank you
so very interesting uh before I ask
members of the the cabinet if they've
got any questions just got one for
myself
um the the current engagements um on
your last side you referred to 24
Community sessions
are they all going to be online are they
a mixer of online and actually going out
to the communities and in which case how
do you select which communities to to
engage with we've got I'm conscious of
the fact we've got a lot of different
communities and spread out over a large
geographic area in both districts and a
lot of it's fairly sparsely populated
so those 24 sessions are actually all
planned to be in person and so we're
assuming
um that the online survey will sweep up
the majority of people unlikely people
who are both
um you know kind of used to engaging
online and through survey platforms but
who are also very familiar with the work
of the council and likely engage in
other ways too those 24 sessions are
really designed to capture the people
who don't typically engage across the
different seldom heard voice groups that
we'd highlighted
um previously that's not to say that we
won't encourage online participation
when we get there and if people feel
comfortable to do so you know they'll
have a postcard to take away and they
can do it in their own time
um so not to Discount that that they
might do that that way and then the
other thing I think is important to say
is that we totally expect a bit of a
snowball effect so we've already seen
the sort of wealth of knowledge and
enthusiasm to participate in this
particular engagement I suspect when we
start turning up to different events we
will learn about where other community
success who we should go and speak to
who would who is most knowledgeable most
kind of able to help the engagement
further along as we go oh that's good so
it's a flexible processor yeah thank you
any other questions members of the
cabinet councilor Derek Davis
[Music]
I remember the strategy meeting that we
made a commitment that we were going to
include
baber's commitment the Armed Forces not
just the Covenant but Armed Forces in
general and there's no mention
whatsoever
in in this refresh and it's it should be
part of the priorities that should be
part of the strategy and it's not even
mentioned at all Ergo it's not mentioned
in the uh the presentation because
they've obviously not had a steer that
it
to ensure that we pay more than just lip
service to the governor but actually
commit ourselves to the Armed Forces
families that live in the district
serving the district and also the
Veterans as well
the priorities if you look on page 113
um under the the strong communities
theme you'll see that it's full of our
commitments to the Armed Forces Covenant
but um I I take a point I think Shaheen
if it's possible as part of that
Community engagement to to reach out to
the military veterans and that that
would be very helpful thanks
you know goals and our priorities and
it's not in there it's on page 113 of
your agenda pack
looking at the present
no it's not it's not in the presentation
you're quite right and
um I just asked if Shaheen can can pick
up on it but it is listed in our
um priorities
it has been included
yeah I'll respond
um so the presentation has include
priorities
or get them to a place that was well to
be honest fits on the slide and then
also
um is is something that we would take to
sessions to make sure that they're
really understandable from the with the
communities and residents that we're
talking to we do already have planned
some sessions with former veterans
particularly the Gurkha Community here
in bayborough
um and so we will be bringing that
specific priority to them and including
it in the sort of broad range of
sessions that we are running
um but there is also something about
making sure that we're capturing the
priorities in a way that is
um both easy to communicate and kind of
easy to understand from a community and
Resident perspective and so that's
probably why we're sort of not on the
side but they are in the longer list of
priorities that you have there and
they've not been dropped
thank you
any other questions Castle saw
risk you were thinking of what you were
expecting on the online survey
uh we were talking about this with
um the project team today
um I think we will look at what previous
online survey response rates have been
for the council and then be able to make
an assessment from there I think it's
hard to say especially with this type of
process and with the tight timelines
that we're working towards exactly how
many people we expect to have and what
we would consider a good representative
sample of the communities that we're
trying to engage but we can make some
inferences
um as and when it's relevant and
appropriate and I think also importantly
to say there is a kind of associated
comms plan that goes with the engagement
and we will both be checking in on the
response rate for the citizen lab online
survey on an ongoing basis and then also
promoting in the challenge channels
where we see that we're getting either a
particularly low response rate to
encourage participation all the way up
until the 15th of November
okay Council soul
um
I was wondering how
you were going to feed all the responses
and the data that you get
into strategy formulation
um because
um having done similar exercises myself
I know that you end up with a flood of
data and
how have you
or have you worked with the council team
the strategy team to to to get the a
good coherent data parcel
uh really great question thank you
um so in terms of the way that we're
going to capture the data we will have a
central tool for all of those
facilitated sessions which will be
structured around the content framework
so that already provides us a sort of
model
um for us to be and there's lots of us
running these sessions so for us to be
inputting what we're hearing and what
people are saying in the sessions into
one
um as sort of into one place then what
will need to happen is a sort of
triangulation between what we've got on
the online survey and what we hear in
the facilitated sessions to be able to
then form the insights that feed into
the corporate plan
um sometimes a little more art than
science
um and so I think we have to remain open
to the diversity of perspectives that
we're going to get but also the
different ways that people will choose
to communicate that back and find a way
within the internal project team which
we've started to talk about already of
how we're going to manage all of that
incoming data and then just to say on
the new local side it's not just me that
we have a team of people working behind
the scenes here who are going to be
really deep in the analysis and
interpretation kind of mode once we've
got a few of those sessions under our
belt and then really importantly I think
you know as an internal project team
we're sort of keeping an experimental
mindset which is if it's not working if
we're not if we're not kind of engaging
on the right questions or necessarily
getting the right input that we need how
might we Flex some of the questions how
might we have flexibility within the
sessions to be able to tease out that
information in a better way and we'll
continuously review that as we go
through the engagement process
best control
thank you Chad I I was particularly
interested in the engagement planning
and the offer of bespoke sessions for
counselors
um and there's a great long list of
engagements there
um how will this all be communicated to
um members of the council for them to
actually
come on board to make sure that the
engagement does go the way you want it
to
great
um fabulous we would love
um all the more kind of people who are
out there talking about the engagement
engaging with communities on these
questions all the better we already have
two also we're doing some training
already for some of the vcsf
organizations who are who are planning
to either host the session
um on our behalf or who are going out
and talking to Residents so you are
welcome to join those sessions they'll
be I can't remember the dates off the
top of my head but the invites are
coming out imminently there's one in the
morning one in the evening to
accommodate different schedules and then
we're also talking about having
something well bespoke for officers and
counselors and so that you have the
space and the freedom to interrogate the
content framework ask us questions about
facilitation techniques learn hopefully
we will have got a few sessions under
our belt by then maybe learn some of the
lessons that we're learning along the
way and feel really confident to then go
out and and talk about this work or
direct people either to the online
survey or or to a facilitated session
follow up my
my son here is not the fact that we're
going to do that and you believe things
are available how is it going to be
communicated and if I'm quite Frank
about it constantly communicated to
remind
during all the sessions and the six-week
online survey how can the message be
driven home and I'm just asking the fee
if there's a program to engage with
counselors I would have said every week
at the very least in the six week period
every Fortnight that reminder that
constant message because I'll be honest
with you so much stuff comes across a
councilor's plate that it is difficult
to keep track and we've been through so
many six-week consultations over the
years we can't remember which ones we're
involved in at any given moment so I
think it's important to drive that
message home with regular communication
and and you know Punchy communication if
you don't mind my saying
thank you chair and and just to
reiterate we will we do have a
Communications plan that sits behind the
the engagement approach
um obviously yourselves are key to
helping us get that message out there so
yes we'll be doing lots to provide
updates to yourselves and all counselors
and we can certainly use our existing
channels to do that but our plea would
also be to obviously for yourselves for
group leaders
um you know to talk to your to your
fellow counselors and encourage that
participation we'll be more than happy
to provide supporting material in order
for you to be able to do that
um so any suggestions that you've got
around how we can add some value
um to some communication messages to
encourage participation would be great
laugh
I promise
after all our priorities um our vision
our corporate plan so we need to promote
it as much as we can councilman crawl
yeah I think we'll have a discussion
about exactly how the message can be got
across I'm I'm always concerned about
drift over the course of a six-week
period And I would hate to see
don't be missed
Sarah
just do um answer partly some of the
question that councilor saw um asked
earlier about the Insight Gathering and
and how we feed that back I just wanted
to give some reassurance that during
that whole six-week consultation we will
obviously be keeping abreast of some of
the main themes that start to come out
of that and we will of course provide
you with with updates as cabinet
throughout that period until we get to
the point um hopefully I think it's the
4th of December where we've already got
a date in the diary with you where we
can then formulate that strategy a bit
more so I just wanted to give you that
reassurance
any other questions
Council McLaren do you have any
questions
right we'll um we'll move into debate
does anyone wish to make any further
comment from members of the cabinet
are we all happy
good well um thank you very much Shaheen
that was a great presentation and thank
you for answering all the questions
um uh it's quite clear that uh the the
strategy you've got there is is very
comprehensive
um we've got quite a bit of work to do
in a fairly short period
um but thank you very much
uh oh Castle or crawl did you want
any second now yes
so
um
uh where it was yes so yeah thank you
Shaheen for coming along
um members of the cabinet we've we've
got uh the recommendation that's been
proposed and seconded to pursue and to
conduct this engagement it is after all
what we said we were going to do
um so really it's let's get on with it
all happy to go to the vote
we'll go to the vote
thank you chair please scroll down to
the
[Music]
group have to skip one
thank you
excuse me I'm not logged in would it be
okay for a hand raise
it absolutely
you are in favor in favor thank you
thank you chair that that's seven votes
four that's carried great thank you
thank you
um okay moving on so it's back to item
nine paper BCA 23 17 uh the cost of
living review of the six month plan and
Beyond and I'd now like to invite the
cabinet member for customers digital
transformation and Improvement to
introduce the support councilman craw
thank you Jeff
I'm uh very pleased to introduce report
BCA 2317 and the cost of living review
of the six-month plan and Beyond
the report provides a summary of the
work undertaken in the last six months
and the latest six-month action plan a
draft form this is the third action plan
the councils have developed in response
to the cost of living crisis and being
one of the fastest councils to at least
act in this area the work undertaken has
been coordinated is not just a cross-hub
this Council and its services but many
key stakeholders and particularly I've
mentioned citizens advice who support
residents and the following key areas
and these are the key areas of the um
the plan itself
maximizing income accessing advice food
insecurity fuel poverty and health and
well-being
the cost of living has clearly emerged
as an ever-changing landscape and while
inflation may have fallen from its peak
what has happened has already happened
and it's not going to be reversed so
those increases are things that people
must live with
regarding food and housing prices there
was some good news today that food
prices slightly dropped by 0.1 to 9.9
food inflation which you know coming
from down from 15 means it's still there
it's not going away
uh
high energy costs also continue and
we're entering the colder months and
increasingly with citizens advice and
ourselves we're seeing increased levels
of debt and negative budgets this cost
of living crisis is beginning to show
the signs of becoming a debt crisis and
that means it could be here a lot longer
than mere inflation
the cost of living continues to be a key
priority so we're proposing alongside
the latest six-month plan to develop a
longer term approach we'll be focusing
on prevention building on our
Partnerships including our various other
bodies that we haven't previously
engaged with on this subject the aim is
to ensure we continue to support our
residents long term uh to our help take
questions on the report we have with
today Samantha Lake corporate manager
for customer operations and Elisa Dale a
cost of living coordinator who was one
of the first principals of the cost of
living plan and her appointment has been
key in carrying this out so I'll hand
over to them if you would like
so you are proposing our guests so may I
have a second sorry I'm indeed for
person now have a second to please
councilor Helen Davis
members of the cabinet do any of you
have any questions
councilor Derek Davis
that really is it shows a lot of hard
work that's gone in over the past year
even so you know you're commended on
that
but once again it's become a bit of a
hobby horse but just like the corporate
refresh I think we're missing a trick in
terms of the Armed Forces not asking for
anything special not asking for them to
get uh jump the queue but the important
thing is armed forces Personnel serving
and factions and not disadvantaged and I
noticed in there you've got
um
support does not discriminate against a
non-protected characteristics as defined
by the equality act unfortunately Armed
Forces Personnel serving or or um or or
X and not protected characteristics so
I'd like to see that we can make a note
that Armed Forces will will definitely
not be disadvantaged in any way because
and I know it's just not anecdotally now
um
some of the especially the lower ranks
families are really struggling and
there's a huge stigma attached as you'd
probably be aware but going to food
banks and um in the services that can be
exasperated exacerbated
so I would just like to see particular
attention paid to that if it's possible
hello can I just check that you can hear
me and I'm not blocking the microphone
with my laptop thank you I think it's a
really valid point
um I think that we are very mindful that
there are significant cohorts of people
that are disproportionately impacted by
the cost of living and we've been quite
conscious to try and embed
in a recognition for that for that
throughout our approach in terms of the
support that's been delivered but also
in terms of sort of the communications
approach that we've taken we've tried to
adopt a bit of a twin approach to have
quite targeted Communications and also
more broad Rush that means obviously
trying to recognize where a household is
at a disproportionate level of risk to
try and make sure they can access
information where and when they need it
but also to make sure that it is more
widely available to the general
um I think particularly for issues like
homelessness and other sort of
sort of tendency sustainment issues
particularly upon leaving the Armed
Forces we're quite aware that there's a
relative
and so we
entered reductions as part of our
business as usual but also is recognized
in the plan to try and address that I'm
quite happy to look at maybe specific
ways and needs of that cohort and how we
can support that further going forward
but it's it's definitely something that
we're mindful of in our
cohort in terms of those skills and
abilities to sustain housing and things
like that coming out and how that can
disproportionately make them vulnerable
with these increased pressures
yeah yeah um thank you for that and it's
good to hear um there's obviously and
again it's not about gaining an
advantage but given the transit nature
as you've mentioned about people leaving
the Armed Forces so they may leave in
Portsmouth or older shot and then they
come back to the baber area
um some some may have disappeared from
the system for some time but of course
there's also the the ongoing problem
with the transit with the families being
in transit as well so they may come from
one area to another area don't know the
system aren't aware of the system that's
been that's been by you guys already and
so that needs particular attention and
if I can help in any way in terms of
contract with sapphire and rbl anything
like that and we're more than happy to
do that because you know they do step
through the net
thank you
thank you any other questions come
Council Carlton and then Council saw
um thank you for this It's really
informative
um
sorry of the things that we're doing
and they are really great things let me
just start that before I go on
um but to be able to be eligible for
things like
um
the Lys the HS hsf HAF
or all the others you have to be on the
on the lowest income but what about
those who are slightly over that income
um and I'm struggling just as much if
anything if not more because they're not
eligible for these things are we doing
enough for them are we doing anything
for them they're not in the system how
are we catching them and how are we how
are we supporting them
foreign
yeah so again I think it's really valid
and I think one of the most challenging
things with that particular cohort is
identifying them it's quite easy
very low income household because
there'll be a receipt of the relevant
benefits they're on the radar with
schools it is more of a challenge to
identify households who are on the brink
and just about managing but at a bit of
a risk of not being able to make ends
meet I think that is something that we
have tried to look at more closely in
our look ahead and in the refreshed
action plan and it includes things like
seeing how we can work more closely with
SRP and housing to identify households
who are in debt and building that
holistic understanding of that I think
there's also a huge role to play here in
terms of making every contact count as a
council and recognizing that need when
it first
presents and that's why we've done
sessions with Frontline staff to talk
about the support available so that they
can sign post as and when it's
appropriate on that initial contact some
discretionary support does rely on being
on an absolute low income like L West or
being on free School meals where again
the threshold is really low but there is
also other discretionary support that we
can exercise so the household support
fund through housing if you're a tenant
it does not
threshold it's very discretionary and
they're able to really consider a
person's eligibility based on their
circumstances and What's led to them
being in that point but it's also
raising awareness of things energy
grants and energy advice and that bit
more of a preventative support that's
available to make sure people feel
equipped to sign post and refer at an
earlier stage in the field poverty
toolkit that we developed it did include
support as well for those just about
managing households and households at
risk but it's definitely something that
we would like to do more of as well and
really understand how we can use our
data to identify and really Target those
households at an earlier point
there were any
particular differences or challenges
between
um the market towns and and Villages
because it's not clear how these
initiatives are being made available to
people in The Villages
they're always difficult to to get to
and and identify
so there are unique
unique environment where in terms of
community Transport and also just
prevalence of services in those areas
that you might be likely to to come
across and access to Port
um I think again we've tried to build
some of that into the look ahead plan by
looking at our approach to community
Transport obviously as a county the
majority of that is managed by Suffolk
County so it's looking at opportunities
to to work with our colleagues there but
also you know what sits within our gift
as a local Authority in terms of
sustainable community Transport and
explore things such as that it's also
sort of we've tried to look at ways of
getting information into those spaces
and services into those spaces working
with Partners like citizens advice to
look at
present in different areas and I think
also recognizing that needs in terms of
like fuel poverty and food insecurity
can vary very greatly depending on the
sort of uh nature of the area
and trying to make that information more
accessible by having it available online
like Suffolk Suffolk info link and also
looking at like our digital skills
support and trying to get out into some
of those more secluded
is where there isn't necessarily that
that provision already there so there
definitely is a market difference but
there are also common themes and it's
it's trying to tailor that support to
the area within which we know there's
need does that make sense
okay
Council macro yes I think um both
Council Carter's point about people who
have a husband on the margins or getting
by um getting struggling
we've all experienced at various times
in our lives just getting by and you
know there's a certain disconnect from
people who are outside the benefits
system but still have needs and then
councilor sore's Point regarding
um
Villages and towns I think one of the
aspects of this version of the plan the
third one is that we we tend to make
better use of our links with town and
Parish councils the hyper local approach
is is designed to actually address some
of those points using the local
knowledge that's available not just
using previous partners that we've had
and we've had great success with those
but we need to extend this and we need
to consider this as a longer term
approach so hopefully both those points
can be addressed through that
it was a response too but obviously
Carter's points that's all I wanted to
throw in there okay because it is it is
the feature of the report
thank you councilor saw you have a
question yeah
um regarding the um
now I'm never too sure whether it's HAF
or half program
um
back to my hobby horse of The Villages
um there doesn't appear to be any
provision for transporting children from
The Villages
to the
to the events so unless their parents
have have cars
they can't participate so
how can we address this this this
problem
again I think it's it's a difficult one
because it's understanding the level of
need and actually having that data as to
who we might be missing in those areas I
definitely think it's something that
that could be explored but it would be a
case of working quite closely with
schools to understand actually who are
we missing and what's the level of need
there and I think you can correct me if
I'm wrong Vicky but the locations for
the half programs were very much
centered around those areas of need and
deprivation across the districts and
where it was felt that that need was
greatest so I think we're considering
actually how can we make that more
accessible to those in more rural areas
there's there's definitely a valid point
there and I think it's something that we
can look at but it's it would need
further I think investigation with
schools to really understand actually
who is missing there and and make sure
that that there is a role there possibly
for them to play as well in terms of how
we work better together
thank you
Council Potter
uh yes thank you I just have a question
on the um on the rents uh people have
been finding themselves in debt
obviously you've got this household
support fund that helps uh mitigate the
impact and and that support can you just
sort of expand a little bit more on how
that's helped would you look to sort of
more than mitigate that that help and
try to you know make sure that not in
the same situation come next year when
the cost of living process deepens with
heating and you know making those
horrible choice of heating and eating
and also looking up rent any any sort of
further impacts you can sort of expand
on for us please
yeah so I think this is one of the
really nice ways in which we've
delivered the household support fund for
tenants um is that it is delivered by
our financial inclusion offices and the
application is really accessible on our
website or over the phone
um that's worked really well because
it's meant that every time an
application is assessed it's assessed by
somebody who is by the nature of their
role used to giving benefits and income
maximization advice completing
charitable applications advising on
discretionary housing
so it naturally brings that household
and that individual from a situation
where they are really struggling to
slightly change the narrative into a
more longer term approach and that has
worked really well
um that team are also very closely
linked with our homelessness service so
we're a tenancy and our Gateway team so
where attendance is unaffordable they're
really well placed to give advice about
longer term options to find other
affordable housing or income
maximization to make sure that their
tenancy is sustainable and try and
mitigate that Gap so it does work quite
well in terms of sort of trying to
support households down that sort of
more preventative pathway
any other questions
Council McLaren do you have a question
I've got two if that's okay
um my first question is about the food
coordinator which I think is a very
imaginative appointment how far along
the appointment process are we
sorry for Their Food Network coordinator
role yeah so that's been sent out to
advert by Community Action Suffolk it
was
talking to interview and recruit really
shortly for that role so we anticipate
hopefully or they'll be in a position to
move forward very soon just depending on
obviously the the quality of
applications that we get but they've
recently had
a similar role than East Suffolk to
relative levels of success and also to
Suffolk County so we're quite optimistic
that we should be in a position to move
forward quite soon
a second question
about
um
we were very successful last year with
the warm spaces
which in the then emerged into sort of
community cafes Etc and
some of the coordinators are actually
getting anxious as to whether they will
be able to receive some support funding
this year
so Suffolk County commissioned some
Consultants to look at the impact that
the warm space grants had last winter
and they're finalizing that at the
minute so we're still awaiting an update
as to what the findings of that were and
what funding may or may not
um but the grants team are obviously
very well equipped to give advice and to
chat through what support an
organization may be eligible to access
um so I think for any project
coordinators that are are looking for
sort of security to help continue their
their initiatives they can contact the
grants team either via the form on the
website or they can
give a chat through what else might be
available to support them in the interim
while we wait that confirmation from
County
thank you Eliza thank you
councilman crawl
as an additional suggestion as a
response to councilor McLaren though I'd
also suggest that members locality
budgets can be used on a hyper local
basis to support warm spaces
immunities and I know that there are a
number of these locality budgets which
are not fully spent at the end of the
year
that's actually a very good point yes
we have got that money we do need to
make sure that we use it to its full
full capability okay members of the
cabinet anyone wish to take part in the
debate anyone got anything they'd like
to say councilor Derek Davis
yeah that's a
backup what councilman crore has said
about council is not just with a
locality budget but actually physically
being able to help the whole of the
community's team in everything they do
in this getting the word out getting
residents and matching them up
and being more proactive all counselors
not just cabinet members obviously we
can do that in terms of the holiday
activity fund for Deborah there's two
well three things there first of all I
know in great cornard they've used the
minibus from the Stevenson Center to
help pick up children the locality
officers certainly we had a very
successful half theme shortly and the
locality officers there ensured that it
was on the bus route and that when the
bus times it fitted in between them
because rare buses obviously and and
again counselors can help I seconded one
of the mums and we did a couple of
Journeys down to shotley gate to pick up
children to come up although we did try
and encourage them to walk because it
was a beautiful day so you know as long
as he sticks in your guidance which I
think there's lots of ways that
counselors can support the team but I
think this is an excellent report the
whole thing all the work that's gone
into it it's very detailed and it shows
the program is being made
and I know councilman the crude will
thank the team but you
know I think it's been great piece of
work
thank you thank you
I I yeah I'd like to
um a second that because clearly there's
been a huge amount that has gone into
into this and it is very thorough a
couple of I think interesting statistics
or data in the report that um
really kind of highlights the fact that
is going to take some time
um there's going to be a huge amount of
work that's going to need to go on for a
quite a long period
um Beyond sort of the headlines we see
nationally because
we see
um in the current resection it was if I
just have a quick go back to the report
again sorry I'm
just
to see where
what I was looking at
on page
yeah it's um it's on page 80 that of the
key information
um we see the the uh the rate of
inflation
has fallen um to 6.3 and I know that's
the CPI age rate and there are a number
of different indices that are fairly
similar but give slightly different
figures your CPI cpih whether it
includes or excludes food energy and
non-alcoholic drinks but the key key one
for me I think is the fact that um uh
the rate for the food and and
non-alcoholic together is still high
although it's dropped a lot is still
13.6 and that's a number you don't often
hear in in the media that they focus on
the fact that the cpih has reduced to
6.3 but if you look at just food and and
non-alcoholic alone it's still
significantly higher than that and and
that's the thing that's going to have a
huge impact on people the the other
um
data that's that's here which is it's
quite worrying is is the fact that that
homelessness cases are increasing it by
a huge amount so we've got 31 uh
increase on last year but more
importantly and 92 percent increase in
homelessness as a result of domestic
abuse so there's there's going to be a
long-term knock-on effect that we're
going to have to respond to for a
considerable period
anyone else got anything else that they
wish to say castle McCraw just that I
think page 93 of the report which shows
you the infographic and highlights tells
you about the story
um
five and a three-quarter million nearly
uh distributed since the plan was first
approved
and that's a significant amount of money
but it's also a significant amount of
resources and not just supplied by
ourselves but um it just shows that
pre-planning and continuing that plan
works
I think the team have done a great job
yes and that infographic in its entirety
is excellent it's it's got all of the
key data there at a glance it's it's so
helpful so useful and um uh it shows
what has been done and and um that the
benefit of it all
so thank you Alyssa thank you
I think we'll move to the vote
thank you chair that wrote a sound
progress members will have to scroll
down to the blue line on the page
thank you members that's seven what
votes for that's uh unanimous
great thank you very much
okay moving on
we've got the next item is item 12 11.
11 of course
BCA 2319 the labor mid Suffolk District
Castle electric vehicle infrastructure
implementation plan I'd like to invite
the cabinet member for environment to
introduce the report Castle Potter
yep thanks very much chair uh so it's my
pleasure to introduce this report a
draft of the emerging Beaver Miss
Suffolk and District Council EV
infrastructure plan uh referred to as
ebit for short
the Suffolk local authorities members
all in 2019 recognized the climate
emergency setting in their aspiration of
making the county of Suffolk carbon
neutral by 2030.
in the same year tailpipe emissions were
then responsible for almost a fifth
that's around 19 of the UK's total
domestic greenhouse gas emissions this
demonstrated significant of the impact
therefore and the need to reduce and
remove tailpipe permissions in response
to climate change and further highlights
to the goal of decarbonization of
Transport is a key action in order to uh
achieve the overall goal of carbon
neutrality the UK is committed to ending
the sale of new petrol and diesel cars
now as We Know by 2035 it's therefore
widely accepted there'll be a shift to
EV vehicles in the coming years what's
important is that the rollout for
infrastructure to support this to keep
up with the demand is important for all
councils to demonstrate a commitment to
assist it laying out how they intend to
play their role in the whole
infrastructure rollout itself the
district level plan will be
complementary to the emerging Suffolk
County council's EV Saturday EV in the
plan utilizes predictions regarding the
likely uptake of these figures which
have been projected by consultancy
modeling work this has been done both by
transport East and Suffolk County
Council these make estimations on how
much public AIDS charge points will be
installed across the districts for each
two to five years and that runs up until
2014. Dave will address how the council
might be able to install EB charge
points upon their own land and also how
they'll help communities and businesses
play their part in infrastructure
rollout
in order to make those recommendations
on where the council may be able to take
the lead as landowners in infrastructure
installation a GIS map tool has been
developed helping to inform officers
where installations may be appropriate
and useful
it should be noted that the suggestions
regarding potential locations for
installations are still all subject to
further investigation and each
installation will be dependent on
feasibility factors these include power
supply connectivity but the list of
potential locations provides a very
useful start point for both the council
and its partners
there's no specific funding that's
attached to this plan but it's intended
to be used as a tool to leverage
investment to EV infrastructure this
ensures that councils are then prepared
for ideas on where infrastructure could
be usefully implemented as and when
funding is secure
if cabinet members are happy with the
councils having and Publishing an event
and Dodge really happy with the
framework and the content that the plan
so far then it's recommended therefore
for members to agree the plan and
delegate the further drafting with
ongoing feedback in mind
the publishing the plan document then
will be completed to the director for
economic growth
change
and that ends my introduction to this
report
thank you guys supporter
um you're proposing the report may I
have a seconder
Council Carter
members of the cabinet do you have any
questions
counselor Derek Davis
yeah my question is really
I see that
that we have quite an ambitious
some would say
predicted evcp requirement
um
663 by 2040 or even 112 in the next two
years and yet we we're only looking the
short-term requirements that
um we we built we put in
um in Baba 29-52 for public use there's
quite a disparity there how are we going
to make up the short form
and and I've got a follow-up question
that that's the thing how we're going to
make up not sure for first of all
um refer that to Catherine Davis please
yeah thank you
thank you thank you
um so the figures that are demonstrated
there in the event about the prediction
of the amount of charges that we'll need
are a total figure of publicly
accessible charges so it's not expected
that the council will lead on that
entire rollout and some of that will be
delivered by sort of commercial partners
thank you
yeah thanks I do have the advantage of
hearing the presentation yesterday so
that that's really helpful but I think
that um my my next question is how do we
encourage Aid The Village Halls to put
more EV charging points in themselves
and also how do we encourage businesses
and is it possible and I include myself
in this to have a really simple idiot's
guide about how how you can get an EVC
to be outside your Village Hall
um yes so our kind of strategy to help
facilitate that for our communities and
businesses is to provide good quality
information and so as you suggest a
toolkit and a kind of you idiot's guide
as you say to how to install a charger
um is something that we can develop as
part of a toolkit and at the moment we
tend to sign post to the plugin
program for
any Village Halls community centers
sports clubs and that kind of facility
because that is some funding that
Suffolk County Council have secured for
exactly that purpose and in terms of our
businesses we will work with them
um
via the UK SPF funding
um we have some funding secured through
that to deliver more EV charge points
and
set up a grant scheme for our visitor
economy businesses for that
yeah thank you for that all I would say
is no disrespect to our Suffolk County
Council colleagues but a lot of parishes
still don't know what's available so the
sign person is probably not working as
well as it could do and perhaps that's
because
a bit of a reaction thing rather than
being proactive
people see the plug-in suffer program if
there is a lack of awareness and we're
we're going to be delivering some
climate action Community Road shows in
the coming month and we will be
signposting for local communities to the
plug-in Suffolk program via those events
thank you
any other questions
Council McLaren do you have any
questions
okay we'll move it over into deep
debates anyone wish to say anything
members of the cabinet
right well I think um we're all it's a
very thorough report
um and uh thank Daniel for the
introduction and and Catherine thank you
for all the effort you put into this and
um uh it we just got to get these these
rolled out as
the difficulty I think is that we are a
very spread out rural area and it's
making sure we can provide identify and
provide EV charging points in the
locations where they're really going to
be needed
um and it's not just in the towns but
it's everywhere else but even even
within our towns that Hadley at the
moment has just got the two and and to
see additional locations and come
forward and Hadley would would be very
helpful there so um uh I'm very happy
with the plan as it is so we'll move to
the vote
thank you members that's seven votes for
that's unanimous
thank you
item 12 paper BCA 2320 employer support
and volunteering policy I'll now invite
the cabinet member for people and places
to introduce the report councilor saw
thank you chair
um I'm pleased to introduce
a gender item 12 report number BCA
2320 employer supported volunteering
policy
um as was so evident during the pandemic
volunteers play an important role in any
active and engaged community and we see
the difference volunteers make across
our districts every day
but between March 2020 and may 2021
around one in three voluntary Community
faith and social Enterprise
organizations reported a decline in the
number of their volunteers
volunteering currently is a historic low
in England people who are lifelong
volunteers broke their habit during the
pandemic and they haven't got it back
yet
data from the Charities AIDS foundations
UK giving report found that only 13
percent of people said they volunteered
in the last year compared with 17
pre-pandemic
representing about 1.6 million fewer
people volunteering over that over the
past five years cash report also reveals
something that we all know that
volunteering is overwhelmingly The
Preserve of older people
the implementation of an employee
supportive volunteering scheme has the
potential to LIT to deliver benefits for
both councils and the local community as
well as well-being benefits for those
undertaking volunteering creating a
win-win situation for all involved
a recipient organizations I.E the
Charities gain skills advice and
expertise whilst our employees achieve a
sense of giving back and making a
difference
they also gain the opportunity to
develop key skills in areas such as
coaching leadership and organizational
abilities in return the councils enhance
their employer brand and reputation with
their employees residents and wildest
and wider Society whilst improving
communication and understanding of the
local community
through an ESV scheme the councils can
support their work towards creating
social value and it contributes to our
priority and outcomes
a recent report from ncvo found that
individuals were likely to work uh for
an employer that encourages and promotes
volunteering
of 80 of those who took part in
volunteering reported increased
Community awareness 65 percent had
increased communication skills and 59
reported an increase in confidence
the council currently has no formal
policy on volunteering in place and does
not actively offer any provision for
employee supported volunteering unlike
many of our neighboring organizations
including the County Council Ipswich
Borough Council and East Suffolk
District Council all of which support
their staff to volunteer or engage with
voluntary bodies through
employer-supported volunteering
first ecv policy for the councils and
I'm both excited and pleased to present
this report today
Professor Derek Davis
members of the cabinet any questions
councilor Derek Davis
you can make a suggest
a form of a question
I I think this is brilliant absolutely
great and I totally agree about the
amount of volunteers we saw during covid
which shows there is a willingness among
our communities to get involved and to
help and one of the things that I've
noticed as well is the amount of
youngsters would you agree that that
have been involved is it possible in
this scheme and not just to promote
support our own
employees to offer a blue bad like a
blue Peter badge type reward so people
can a be be rewarded in a tangible way
for doing the volunteer work and also
when those young people then go to an
employer and say look I've done this and
I've got my
baby badge whatever it's called to to do
that
um I think I'm going to defer to the
officers on this one
um thank you
um we are kind of starting to do that we
started a process of
rewarding our employees who do currently
already volunteer so um
Bethany has been working with our comms
team we've been putting things and
working together and we've been
conducting surveys of all of our
employees who have participated who
volunteer for organizations within the
district
um those that are volunteered if they
work for a local organization within the
district then we are awarding a
phenomenal sum of funding just to
support that particular organization but
also that individual being will be
welcome
celebration event that will be held so
end of a house or a locality or
somewhere in their localities
and as a result and I think we could
take that further like you say a
certificate is something that
demonstrates that that young person or
younger employee has an
on a place but also to support their
their communities in XY NZ so we've
already started that process that's
I believe with a view of doing that
celebration event towards the the latter
part of this year November
in November so we have set up some comms
but we can re-share that if that would
be of interest if you've managed to
recognize that you have a sway of
information to come come past and good
come through your email so we can read
share that if that
would be anyone else got any questions
councilor Helen Davis
thank you yeah I agree it's a brilliant
report and it's really worthwhile I've
done that when I was working and I've
Clark's husband does it now in our
village he cleans the road signs and
cuts back the vegetation and it might
only be a little bit of work but it has
such
so I think this is this is so worthwhile
I did have a Wonder
um
councilor Derek Davis referred to
the younger cohort of volunteers is this
something
BBB extended to local sixth form
colleges for example
I'm sure the uh
us have a have a view on this and I know
that there is work that we do with
schools
um certainly this report is very much
focused on the support that the council
provides to its own employees in terms
of volunteering but certainly something
to pick up with the cabinet member going
forwards is how we as a council support
volunteering within our wider
communities we really work closely with
Community Action suffer work closely
with volunteering matters and it's
something that we can look to do
things get quite complicated once you're
looking at volunteers that are under the
age of 18 that can be complicated both
for the individuals and for the
organizations that are hosting them that
doesn't mean it shouldn't happen and
there are all sorts of benefits to young
people volunteering it just there's
another layer of things that you just
need to work through to make it kind of
um safe for everyone ultimately and but
that's certainly something that we can
pick up as I say this report is very
much about the support for employees but
the role that we play in supporting
volunteers out in the wider Community
can be almost kind of phase two or
something that we continue
the cabinet member
any health questions
McLaren
thank you my question well my question
is about the type of volunteering
I'm just going to be
councilor Davis Derek Davis to the
question
um when people volunteer that the likes
of the Armed Forces or the Coast Guard
or something like that my concern when I
read the report was that a maximum of
three days paid leave seemed a bit
restrictive would there be any
flexibility in that amount
Tom was that something
that's poor Finance has calculated
the cost of these three days
um we know that not everybody is going
to take three days
um volunteering in fact uh experience
shows um looking at other councils and
looking at the County Council that their
experience was I think 1.6 to 2.3
percent of the workforce took it up so
um although it is a exceptionally good
scheme with a lot of benefits there is a
cost associated with it that I think we
need to be aware of
um
Tom so if I could just bring Bethany in
because there's a relationship between
some of their other council's policies
that Bethany would just be able to to
explain to you and then I just have a
very small point which is that anybody
can volunteer outside of this policy any
of our staff can volunteer as much as
they wish to this policy is just about
given a certain amount of time within
their paid time for clearly people can
volunteer beyond that but Bethany did
you want to
so just to answer your question um
cancer Karen um members of the river
reserves forces actually have a special
relief
um
honestly it comes underneath the leaf
policy says it's a standalone issue
separate to the volunteering policy so
um I hear what you're saying it is just
that Reserve forces are then covered
elsewhere
right if there are no further questions
we'll move to debate
councilman craw
L yeah I'm particularly pleased to see
that the recommendation included 510
that the volunteering allowance is not
limited to new volunteering because the
existing amounts of work should be
recognized and you don't want to get
into that situation where only new users
get the insurance rates in their first
year and everybody else just gets stuck
with the old race or increased this is
something we should support and maybe we
can raise it a little bit beyond 2.3
percent
voluntary activity but fundamentally
there's no Community can live without it
so we should go go full full hog on this
thank you councilman crawl anybody else
all right
certainly yeah I think um
clearly that there is obviously a
financial
um uh cost to this but that's more than
made up in terms of uh the fact that it
clearly uh is valued by those that take
part it makes them uh appreciate what
they're doing volunteer in terms of
volunteering but also it I'm sure it
helps in in
in their employment as well in terms of
their their morale
um
I
I agree councilman Crawley we need to um
promote this as much as we can and
um make sure it's a success and
certainly uh in terms of the percentage
uptake
could probably beat the Suffolk County
council at 2.3 that would be
um that's a a Target to aim for but um
uh I think um just everything in the
report is um
something I think we we should endorse
and and proceed with so on that note oh
councilor Derek Davis
yeah I'm just gonna
maybe not a blue Peter badge
perhaps the lanyard that indicates
whether it's purple gold blue whatever
you know that that would say I'm a
volunteer and I do this and then
somebody can say oh how come you've got
X lanyard and you could explain and if
they don't they're already aware of the
policy they can use it as an example so
exactly as as you and councilman crew
have said you know we're promoting it
we're among the officers because all the
other bits are absolutely great but
sometimes it just if they want to wear
it of course some of them might want to
hide their lie under a bush or whatever
but you know just an idea
okay
sorry uh quickly just just to follow on
with that like with the um
or you can put it on your CV and
actually it does so much for you but it
gives
young people a sense of purpose within
their Community instead of sort of being
ostracized I suppose by the community
saying well I hooked up with this this
and this and not only do I get the
rewarding benefit from it but I I have
something physical on my CV which will
then help me later in life there's
definitely something we should be
promoting I think it's brilliant
thank you
okay we'll move to the vote then
vote it's not
thank you members uh that vote
uh seven votes four and that's carried
thank you
item 13 paper BCA 2321 revised
safeguarding policy for children young
people and adults at risk I'll now
invite the cabinet member for people and
places to introduce the report Castle
saw
FBA 2321 revised safeguarding policy
children young people and adults
um the purpose of this report is to ask
cabinet to approve the revised
safeguarding policy to ensure that an
overarching approach to safeguarding is
embedded across the council's
identifying roles and responsibilities
of employees counselors and volunteers
it also will apply to organizations
delivering on behalf of the council this
revised policy outlines the procedures
to be adopted by both councils in
ensuring the safety of children young
people and adults at risk the revised
policy picks up all current legislative
requirements and expectations of local
authorities and provides an easy to use
set of guidance on how to report a
safeguarding concern
support this policy officers have
developed a thorough and detailed action
plan which will see an increased focus
on a regular annual review of the policy
via the council section 11 audit process
greater sharing of related guidance and
procedures employee and counselor
training and the development of
council-wide safeguarding Champions
group made up of officers from Frontline
teams to share information and best
practice
the policy has been shared and consulted
on with an extensive list of Partners
including the Suffolk safeguarding
partnership our health alliances local
Authority partners and the safeguarding
training team at Community Action
Suffolk
I'm glad to say all of which have
complemented the revised draft as
comprehensive with easy to follow
guidance
I have pleasure in submitting the report
thank you Council saw so you're
proposing a report may I have a second
councilor Derek Davis thank you
before we go into questions I just
wanted to
um
thank Rachel Rachel Young our assistant
manager for Community safety because I
understand she's put in a huge amount of
work into this report and we can see
that it is very thorough and it does me
for a very good and interesting reason
and I do what to call me
acknowledge that in in this meeting so
cabinet members any questions
Derek Davis
you probably won't know this off the top
of your head Rachel but how many
accounts or Council workers have DBS
checks already
um and is it a an easy format for them
to have and perhaps the leader might
this do you think all counselors should
be DBS checked
foreign
do I think all counselors should be DBS
checked I
I
hadn't even considered that um
I don't know I think that might be um
Overkill I don't it's it's a DBS check
is a very thorough it's a very detailed
thorough process time consuming
um
I I don't think we can there's something
we need to pick up on outside of this
meeting but uh
what was the first part of the question
I'm not sure we have the actual figure
for that but we are I know that we have
in Rec in developing the whole policy
obviously we've included DBS checks in
in here and what that has done has
instigated us to do some work around
what roles that sit within the council
required to be DBS checked are they DBS
of the offices DBS check which they
should be if there's a a tick a book to
be ticked um but also then what's the
review period for those DBS checks for
those officers that have been imposed
for a significant number of years
because we recognize that
have some new DBS at the beginning of
their employment and they're imposed for
more than 10 years and actually we need
to make sure that we're doing those
regular checks so for example I know
that I've received a long list of folks
within my team and I've been going
through those that require DBS is it
still current and that information is
being used at the moment by HR so we
will be able to generate those reports
but we probably just don't have the
specific figures for you now
all locality offices are DBS shaped yeah
yeah thank you
unsupervised access to um children and
vulnerable adults and we have a very
long list in terms of those staff at the
moment but as
Vicki says we are revising that
and and our policy is very clear
um that people's DBS in those relevant
posts will be reviewed every three years
thank you Kathy
any other questions
Council Carter
weird feedback I'm really sorry
um so a couple if okay and I'll I'll try
and separate them
um
but uh children young people that aren't
I suppose in the system are being
flagged up but are at risk
we are aware that it's happening and I
think that covert again was a good
example where we very easily highlighted
the vulnerable children and young people
and managed to
although
be a vet someone was only during the
school time so we only took them out of
their homes during then but what are we
doing to work closely with
those around them
to ensure that they are getting help
before against you late if you have
children that aren't attending school
children and young people that aren't
attending school or college or for
whatever reason
um don't have social workers don't see
people on the regular
what are we doing to help them what are
we doing to seek them out
I'll be doing anything
I think it's you're absolutely right and
I think the purpose the purpose policy
is very much an internal document about
our roles and responsibilities whilst we
are here at work and obviously we don't
provide many of those statutory services
that are perhaps provided by either
summer County Council Probation Services
but we do so support younger people in
lots of different ways so it is
important that we train our staff we
train members we train our volunteers
and also any organizations that we're
commissioning services from recognize
the signs where support is needed and
they know how to make those referrals
they can check in with team members of
the team to understand actually this is
what I saw this is what I how it made me
feel what do I do about it and so it is
around supporting people wherever they
are whether that's in the communities in
a particular role to report a
safeguarding concern so that can be
picked up by the relevant organizations
which sit in the the County Council but
other things that we do as a district
for example is around ensuring that we
provide warm safe homes for for those
that need it so our social housing is in
good standard
um things like the holiday and food
activity funding which is about
supporting those young people who may
not have access to warm food so it's
where they might we're just kind of not
purposely neglected but neglected in
that sense we've launched our youth
social prescribing program which is
about putting youth workers in schools
to work with young individuals in that
kind of preventative space to ensure
that we do capture them and try to
remove barriers from accessing support
whether that's access to a local
football Group Transport to an arts
class whatever that might be so they
have support in school but as well as
outside of school so where we can do
more we absolutely will and of course we
support a number of local community
voluntary organizations within the
district through our community grants
and also we have different funding
Awards throughout the year and we
certainly would make sure that some of
the kpis account the the impact we would
like to see for young people are are in
there as well so I will say that we I
could probably go on and pick up other
services as well around public spaces
open you know public realm but play
areas some of our sport Provisions
there's a lot going on that would help
to support to capture some of those
young young people
um and just about the system
um I suppose there's a long
mental health waiting list for all age
groups
um is there is there anything that we
can do about that locally and also what
about people that are getting
lost in the system so they they think
that they've made a referral and they
haven't
um I think they're getting more
difficult I suppose just sign posting
people to the right help and then
perhaps even just a follow-up to ensure
that they haven't
just gone to see a GP and it's ended
there but they are actually on a waiting
list and there is somebody looking out
for the more coming for them at some
point
I think what we would need to do with
regards to that is to take that away so
we are Partners or members of the Civic
safeguarding partnership Forum which
meets meets regularly to discuss issues
such as that and I suspect that there is
um there are there are processes in
place to try and do that so we can raise
that the next partnership meeting and
make sure that we come back and provide
you with an update
representation on the integrated care
partnership board the Suffolk
safeguarding board and the um two
Alliance committees for the Ipswich in
east and west
um we we I and we um as a collective of
multi-agency individuals regularly make
representations about the
um lack of services and to meet the
demand in terms of young people's Mental
Health
foreign
do you have any questions I just say
I'll just say Joe I was going to ask the
same question as counselor Davis asked
okay thank you thank you
we'll move to debate now
does anyone wish to say anything
Castle or crore
yeah I'm just looking through the report
I think it's important not to try and
massively change the content of the
report and I think it's important to
note and to point out in this public
forum that all our staff receive
mandatory first and second level
training as part of their inductions and
it's refreshed there is mandatory
training for all councilors renewable
every three years and
um yeah having been married
to teach you all my life and I'm very
aware of what risks can exist and how
many things around I'd be little
concerned about uh putting a whole bunch
of people who are pretty like unlikely
to have the need for DBS training and
therefore blocking people who really do
need
DBS training there is only so much
training available from the trainers but
so
um I think I think we're probably okay
to make the suggested change would
actually change our policy so I think
perhaps at the next refresh that could
be considered however but I don't think
we can consider it now
fully in support of this because who
wouldn't be
I think you've got some cruel anybody
else
in which case are we all happy to move
to the vote on the policy as it
currently stands
yep we'll move to the vote
thank you members that's seven votes for
that's carrot
thank you
right moving on to item 14 the the last
item and that is paper BCA 2315 the
confidential minute of the meeting held
on the 5th of September
um we will go into closed session if
there are any comments on the
confidential minutes
so does anyone wish to comment
so we're happy to go to the vote to
approve these minutes
then we'll go straight to the vote then
share that voters now
thank you members that's six foots four
and one abstention so that's character
thank you right well that concludes this
evening's meeting the date and time of
the next meeting it'll be Tuesday the
7th of November at 4